la paf b je suis pas une chanson dès la
première chanson chrétienne a écrit qui
s'appelle mythomane mythomane oui alors
ils étaient très contents que je la
fasse parce qu'elle est très jolie
chanson qu'il ait fait ça va mais voilà
alors si sa chanson fétiche et commentée
de sang dans la bd là là je me sens très
bien voir ça va allonger la tech
situerait pas des fois tu peux être
reste perpignan oc on en a toujours mais
pas finir ma g je vis toujours avec les
gens qui sont là bas et j'y vais souvent
et ça va c'est que pour épouser deux ans
this way des garanties sur sa pelouse
s'il ya des moments où j'ai eu envie
très fort mais bon quand on fait un
choix il faut faire avec elle elle ment
vie aussi elle s'imagine pas qui c'est
mais tu penses pas que finalement ce qui
t'a manqué c'est un peu tes rides veut
dire ça mais peut-être se mettre
d'accord avec moi ce qui t'a manqué dans
la vie finalement c'est d'avoir un homme
a pris goût à lyon quelqu'un qui te
pousse dans certaines directions qui tu
retiens à certains moments qu'ils savent
faire du cinéma au moment de la chanson
bon moment qui tu enlèves de l' aventure
dans le monde tu penses pas ça non ce
qui me manquait sur moi c'est
quelqu'un qui m'aime et que j'ai mis six
mois il était dit que quitte effectuer
le passé sa gym visiteurs bien manger je
suis une passionnée alors la passion un
amour c'est avec ce fait moins bien que
laisser tomber
ouais je n'aime pas la médiocrité dans
ce genre là bas